[MUSIC PLAYING]
MELINDA BRIANA EPLER: My
purpose is and always has
been to change the world.
I started with
cultural anthropology,
looking at how change
happens in societies
and how individuals create
change in societies.
And from there I found
the power of storytelling.
I became a
documentary filmmaker.
I moved to LA,
and for 10 years I
was a documentary
filmmaker looking
at HIV/AIDS in South Africa,
women's rights in Turkey,
environmental issues and social
and climate change-related
issues.
That brought me to learn
the power of storytelling
through business, so
I became a consultant.
I worked with entrepreneurs
all the way through Fortune 500
companies launching
mission-driven brands
to really change the world.
And that led me to my dream job.
I moved to San Francisco, I
became a C-Suite executive
in an engineering firm, an
international engineering firm,
I built my own team,
I had no budget.
I was changing the world.
But it didn't quite
work out that way.
It was actually one of the
worst experiences of my life.
I hit rock bottom.
It was so bad that I can't
even talk about it legally.
I learned there the power
of diversity and inclusion
and the need for both.
Diversity is bringing
people to the table.
Key to this,
inclusion is actually
inviting them to speak and to
lead, and we need both of them.
When you're not
included, it sucks.
It really sucks.
I'm sure a lot of you have
been in the situation before.
Unconscious biases,
microaggressions,
macroaggressions, when they
come at you every single day,
you lose your power.
Exclusion is where
good ideas die.
It's a culture.
It's a culture thing.
When we're not welcome,
we're not able to thrive.
That's what's happening
in the STEM fields.
In computer science
degrees, in tech fields,
we're having a revolving door
where people are leaving.
So I crawled myself out
of the hole that I was in,
and I started putting
things into place
and I started hiring people
that really cared about making
a change in that company.
But I kept thinking more.
I kept thinking bigger.
What is the societal change
that needs to happen?
And I realized that most
of the world's problems
boil down to exclusion in
one way or another-- poverty,
environment, education, health.
Bringing diverse and
inclusive leadership,
and having inclusive
innovation, can drive change
in these areas.
Here we are at the center of
innovation in Silicon Valley,
and we have to change
it here and now.
So I started a company.
I started Change Catalyst.
Our mission is to drive
inclusive innovation.
So what is inclusive innovation?
It starts with education, K
through 12, higher ed, coding
schools, boot camps.
Then the workplace--
recruiting, retention,
promotion, and creating
that culture of inclusion.
And then entrepreneurship,
because entrepreneurs
are driving the next wave
of our economy, right?
We need to look at
access to capital, access
to other early-stage resources.
All of these things together,
along with policy-- policy
is often forgotten
in this equation.
Both local policy
and national policy
can really create
change in this space.
And then lastly,
ecosystem development.
So looking at emerging markets,
looking at the digital divide,
really creating these
inclusive tech ecosystems.
So we brought all
of these-- people
across all of these
areas together
for a conference in September
of 2015 called Tech Inclusion.
We explored
comprehensive solutions
to diversity inclusion in tech.
It ended up selling out.
We had a two-day two-track
conference and career fair.
The career fair also sold out.
We had a thousand people.
We had 137 speakers, 27
companies represented
at the career fair, and
it was so successful we
decided to keep going.
So we are now a
team of five people.
We have five conferences
across the US this year,
three career fairs,
two startup showcases,
we're also doing
consulting and training
for companies that
want to do more.
And we're starting to
look across the world.
We're starting to look at
those emerging markets.
How do we develop inclusive tech
ecosystems from the beginning?
So we can learn
what we did right
and what we've done
wrong in Silicon Valley.
So I want to invite you to join
us in developing inclusive tech
ecosystems across the US.
We all have a role to play, and
we can all make a difference.
Think of something that you
can do differently tomorrow,
and make that change.
And focus on solutions.
Come meet us.
We have a table out
here, and look for us
online at TechInclusion.co.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]